the galactic Overlord emperor of the
universe the tyrannical frost diamond
purple Hitler
there are many monikers this entity of
evil goes by but few names capture the
truly terrifying children's opponents
field quite as accurately as Frieza and
in achieving the status of undisputed
dictator over all of creation Frieza has
squashed numerous opponents many of
which dared to stand in his way half of
the appeal Frieza had was his immense
power and how it seemingly kept on
growing in scale so much so the show
pretty much gave up and power levels
after the Frieza portion of the story
not on like a mountain resisting a light
breeze Frieza was laughs in the face of
numerous adversaries leading to their
inevitable death and utter embarrassment
freeze it took great pleasure in
exacting the punishment he dished out
and I gotta say I enjoyed watching it
too with that said I'm totally not mark
and this is the top ten times Frieza
embarrassed his opponent number 10 we
are first introduced to nail as the
attendant to the grand elder guru we
later learned that not only is he a
capable proud fighter but is by far the
strongest namekian on the planet before
piccolo was revived standing tall with
an officially stated power level of
42,000 this reading places him on a
pillar far above the likes of czar bond
and Doria who are at the time freezes
strongest elite soldiers to give you an
idea that's over five times stronger
than Goku was when he got back from
snake way to face Vegeta up until we the
audience see his showdown with Frieza
nail had not once demonstrated his power
in any measure showing tremendous
restraint and poise when in the face of
true adversity however in an effort to
buy time for the Earthlings to make a
wish on the namekian Dragon Balls nail
takes freezer to the other side of the
planet to fight what followed was one of
the most one-sided fights we had ever
seen the show up until this point
reading nails powerlevel free to remarks
at how strong nail actually is and even
mentions how he'd be a valuable addition
to his forces the true scale the
situation isn't realized however until
freezer reveals how strong he is in
comparison 530,000 requiring only
one-tenth of his power to defeat nail
going as far as to say he will only use
one arm when fighting the once composed
nail powers up and explodes forward with
a swift chop to freeze his neck only to
be met by that same icy stare that so
many before had witnessed as promised
with one
I'm freezer rips off his extended I'm
causing nail to collapse the floor in
agony freezer does get a few more hits
in but it's in this moment when nail
realizes the sheer terror he is up
against this entry features solo because
nail never really thought that he could
win this was all an effort to buy time
for the Earthlings however I don't
believe for one second he thought it was
going to be this much of a defenseless
thrashing number nine freezes
affiliation with the sand race is well
documented a warrior race that once
answered to no one became the lackeys of
the crazed purple demigod for those of
you who don't know the character Frieza
was based off of a very specific type of
person in Japan around the late 80s to
early 90s real estate speculators which
Toriyama the creator of Dragon Ball
stated as being the worst sort of people
due primarily to the financial strife
they caused families and other people in
Japan Frieza was hell-bent on becoming
the unquestioned ruler over all the
universe with seemingly hundreds of
planets already under his thumb however
the universe is vast and Frieza has a
finite lifespan so to remedy this issue
he enlisted the help of the Saiyans from
Planet Vegeta and this this is where
things go south to the Saiyans in a big
way effective and efficient in their
role the Saiyans conquered numerous
worlds across the galaxies for freedom
boss he began to notice something the
Saiyans were growing stronger far
surpassing his most reliable forces he
began to think in large enough numbers
and have gone unchecked these sands
could cause him some serious trouble it
was this insecure thought that led to
the extinction of Planet Vegeta with an
energy blast the size of a small planet
with one finger Frieza hurls it towards
the world of a Saiyan
standing between his home and freezes
blast was Bardock the father of Goku who
fires a powerful energy blast towards
Frieza
only for it to have no effect he
realizes the gravity of the situation in
that moment freezes blast that erases
him and his planet from existence for
Saiyans remains after the attentive
extinction Raddatz nappa the Saiyan
Prince Vegeta and cakra also known as
Goku who was sent to Planet Earth
moments before the planet was destroyed
quite a humbling time insane history
number eight as many of you know Gohan
is a very entertaining character even
being heralded as the fighter with the
most latent potential numerous times
throughout this year
so naturally when his friends are in
danger in this situation Crillon piccolo
you would think you would make a
sizeable difference when he cuts loose
and he does save krill in piccolo but
that's about it
Golan's effort to rescue krill in from
drowning at the hands of Frieza has got
to be one of the coolest moments in the
show's history only made better with the
release of Kai and it's superior voice
acting but moments like that only set us
up for a fall and fall Gohan certainly
took once Frieza added some much-needed
reality to the mix Frieza said it best
himself none of you have even a
slightest chance of escape and even
after his n Chi boost
what's goin was healed by den day he
still stood no chance against the
seemingly bottomless pit of power that
Frieza possesses number 7 Dragon Ball
super
along with revitalize interest in the
series brought with it an old friend
Freeza Freeza having just been revived
is all like if I train I could reach a
power level of 1 million and I'm like
yeah whatever
Super Saiyan Goku was like 150 million
and that was ages ago times have changed
and so of the standards of fighting
Frieza
you're in your base form and you expect
to beat Super Saiyan God
I'm stand corrected
now I know what you're thinking go on is
weaker in this scene than he had been in
the past and let's face it he isn't the
most prideful person in the bunch either
but this entry isn't specifically for
Gohan alone prior to this decimation the
Z Warriors had to hold off Frieza
soldiers for a considerable amount of
time during which many of them became
tired starting to lose control of their
respective situation go on in many
respects was the glue that held that all
together even going as far as to protect
piccolo against the likes of sashimi and
togarmah
in Super and the movie resurrection F
the point I'm trying to make here is go
on was far stronger than the current run
of Fighters Earth had to offer without
Goku and Vegeta present the others look
to Gohan for the victory and as soon as
Frieza get out of his chair he added
much-needed perspective to everyone's
situation in his base form resulting in
Gohan calling Vegeta and Goku for help
number 6 this scene is purely exclusive
to the anime in the manga Frieza arrives
and the interaction with nail and guru
plays out as you would expect however in
the anime we are treated to this and
by three namekian warriors who are for
lack of a better term kaki these
nameless warriors stand much taller and
bigger than the smaller five foot tall
Frieza once surrounded Frieza lets them
know that their power levels are
insignificant in comparison to his own
but need us to say they do attack anyway
despite Frieza and nails best warnings
and how does Frieza choose to
counter-attack by breathing Frieza took
these guys out by breathing on them
after killing two or three of them with
a simple exhale of the lungs Frieza
grabs the last one by the neck gripping
tighter and tighter once he is satisfied
that he doesn't know any of the
information he requires he decides to
drop him from a height towards nail on
the ground below moments before the
wounded the Meccan is the crashing to
the floor near nail he is killed by a
blast and through his chest by Frieza
and unfortunately for our next entry
Frieza was far from done dishing out
these beatings on dimensions number 5
the funny thing regarding this
interaction with piccolo is that he is
by far the strongest character in this
series up until this point
well except Frieza but we'll get to that
having just been revived using the
namekian Dragon Balls if he finds
himself the first time on his homeworld
suddenly he senses a fading power off in
the distance on the wastelands of Nanak
he finds nails having been left for dead
by the hands or should I say hand of
Frieza
with what little strength he has left
nail explains that there is a forbidden
technique that their people are capable
merging using this technique
nail and piccolo can pool their powers
together and magnify their strength
creating a super namekian warrior far
stronger than the two warriors would be
seperated once the dust of the merger
has settled piccolo is left stunned by
his own power leaving us with this
wonderful theme yes yes just I can win I
feel great I can yeah yeah yeah you get
the picture needless to say the man is
competent and really so he should be at
this point he's a strongest Z warrior in
the history of the show he arrives just
in the nick of time on the battlefield
to confront Frieza cousing a power level
of over 1 million
and while piccolo puts up a great fight
initially freezer reveals that this is
only his second form and that he has two
others still remaining piccolo believes
that he is bluffing but
oh boy he wasn't paying a quick tribute
to the movie alien Frieza demonstrates
how monstrous he can be while still
technically not trying at all proving
that he is still much faster and
stronger than piccolo could ever imagine
but don't worry piccolo you'll be the
strongest again one day for literally
one day number four to feel the full
brunt of this one let me break it down
this was in a sense a long time coming
for Goku such was the plot at the time
Goku has gotten to overconfident in his
physical abilities having long since
surpassed the likes of Frieza Sal and
majin buu Goku is supremely confident
leading up to his rematch with the
recently revived Frieza having achieved
a new God form in Super Saiyan blue he
has more than a few transformations to
rely now on in battle Frieza side of the
story began as he was revived seeking
out revenge on the scourge that laid
waste to him all those years ago but
before he decides to go confront Goku
and his friends he decides for the first
time in his life to train for those of
you out there that do not know freezes
race isn't significantly more powerful
than any other race in the universe
Frieza and his family simply have a
mutation that makes them uniquely strong
so what happens when a prodigy trains in
earnest a substantial amount is gained
it seems but I'll get to that once all
is said and done
Goku arrives in the battlefields face to
face with what we venue as freezes final
form Frieza says go on Channel let's do
the play Angelo I hate so much - its
Goku replies to be honest Frieza I'm not
so sure I need to get Goku isn't taking
Frieza seriously after they fight for a
while Goku powers off into Super Saiyan
blue form his then current max power
output - which then Frieza answers back
with his newly acquired golden form and
guess what stamina aside this form is
stronger than Goku is current max output
at the time in Super Saiyan blue there
are a few rules in war and war is
exactly what Frieza considered this
battle with goku using some cheap
tactics freezer has goku on death's door
with goku having no one but himself to
blame for letting his guard down he's
lucky that vegeta was there and tagging
what he did what follows is freezes
victory destroying the plan with
everything on it ensuring his victory if
we swoon there to provide a temporal
do-over
Goku would have had
no one else to blame but himself for the
loss of planet Earth and all the
inhabitants of it this was a necessary
and humbling experience for Goku number
three Vegeta a man that for the longest
time was defined by his pride always
blindly believing that he was the
strongest character in the series with
very little proof to back it up it was
this level of delusion and arrogance
that placed him in many embarrassing and
humbling situation few more prevalent
than this one right here having just
undergone a power of after the ginyu
force altercation thanks to a sense of
being provided by Goku
Vegeta's power skyrocketed fully
believing at this time that he was on
the cusp of becoming the legendary Super
Saiyan for decades Vegeta had lived
under freezes Bootheel having to comply
with his every demand now having the
knowledge that he was the one
responsible for murdering his father his
people and his entire planet Vegeta
feels in this moment for the first time
in his entire life that he possesses
enough strength to vanquish the tyrant
that destroyed the world he was destined
to rule over this is the instant where
freezes main battle begins looking down
murderously at Vegeta Gohan and krillen
as he contemplates how best to destroy
them Vegeta while initially taken aback
by freezes arrival gathers his senses
and announces that he has become a Super
Saiyan and will destroy Frieza with the
help of Gohan and krillen once and for
all and to the surprise of even myself
the viewer at the time Vegeta seems to
be doing just that Frieza scholar even
blows up trying to read his energy level
and that's always a good sign confident
in meeting the challenge that stood
before him Vegeta then bared witness to
the grim reality of just how terrifying
freezer could be standing tall with a
power level of over 1 million the Saiyan
Prince that was once talking confidently
was now as silent as a grave until
number two once Frieza unveiled his
second form Vegeta was by and large
frozen in place unable to bring himself
to do anything he watched on as Gohan
Crillon and even piccolo challenged the
monster Frieza
as he continued to grow his power
through transformation a further two
times but the Saiyan Prince had a plan a
plan
many would concede as being a pretty
good one well on paper anyway having
noticed that his last increase was
substantial and far from ordinary Vegeta
came to the conclusion that he was
edging closer and closer to the
Super Saiyan state thus he felt one last
push was needed to tip him over the edge
across that threshold and over into the
realm of legends sounds good right well
this is where things get a little dicey
you see in order for this powerup to
take effect Vegeta would need to sustain
a near mortal wound or injury and be
healed quickly thereafter sounds simple
enough
Krillin provides the blast through the
torso so gaping wound almost certain to
kill him check now all that remained was
for denday to use his newly acquired
healing abilities and all should be
dandy well then they recalled that it
was Vegeta who was responsible for
killing much of his people so initially
dandy refuses bejesus requests to heal
him flying away leaving him to die like
Vegeta did with so many of his other
namekian brothers however shortly after
dende is convinced to heal vegeta
moments before the same prince was to
die Wow imagine if a cheetah had died
there he would have been killed by
Crillon finally Vegeta has fully
recovered now at the zenith of his
abilities Vegeta approaches Frieza now
in his final form confident claiming for
all to hear that he has finally become
what he is wanted for so long to be the
legendary Super Saiyan finally he can
defeat Frieza
or so he thinks while Vegeta's power had
grown substantially Frieza was barely
using a fraction of his full strength
unable to scratch the all-powerful
Frieza the gravity of his actions hits
the Saiyan Prince that Frieza is just
too monstrous for him or anyone that at
no point was he any match for him and
that any effort or hope he had ever had
was completely worthless and unfounded
it is in that moment the Prince of all
Saiyans sheds tears tears that signify
how hopeless the situation actually is
for him before his debt at the hands of
Frieza he pleads with Goku to let go of
any kindness he has and to avenge the
Saiyan race with that he breathes his
last breath dead on the wastelands of
Planet Namek humbled by the ultimate
evil Frieza number 1 there might have
been some contention between what would
get the number one spot on this list but
in reality this was the moment that
inspired me to make this video in the
first place all throughout this arc
Frieza had been portrayed as an
unstoppable monster relentless
vindictive and destructive with an
eloquent speaking voice was made for an
even more unsettling character but as n
who has watched any show as a viewer we
try to anticipate what will happen next
how the hero will overcome the villain
we as viewers look out for common tropes
in shows at this point in the story
Frieza has outmatched every other
character in the cast but what's more is
while doing so was barely even using a
fraction of his power when Goku shows up
to the fight he too is stronger than all
the other cast of characters by a
substantial margin so in the viewers
head space Goku and Frieza are
relatively unknown but large quantities
the fight begins and the battle seems to
be going modestly but well for goku
maintaining his composure and getting a
few good hits in eventually things
settle down when Frieza announces that
while he has enjoyed the workout he's
beginning to grow tired of toying with
him he claims that if he were to power
up to 50% it would suffice to grind Goku
into space dust for all of us the
audience we know that Goku was not
fighting at full power either so this at
least for us acts at the bookmark for
when the fight starts to become more
serious I remember this situation
vividly from when I was sitting
alongside my brother watching on Toonami
way back in the early 2000s the fight
resumes and Goku is immediately put on
the back foot taking a much more severe
thrashing than he had in the past
getting absolutely no offense in on
Frieza however almost at the same time
both myself and my brother reassure each
other that Goku might not be faring well
but he is still yet to use the kaio-ken
technique putting the odds still very
much in Goku's favor having that
multiplier in his back pocket and then a
bombshell is dropped as the guy's a King
Kai's plays are watching the fight
unfold King Kai announces that it isn't
looking good for Goku to which tension
on claims like myself and my brother did
that Goku still hasn't utilized the
kaio-ken technique and therefore should
still be fine cutting in King Kai then
corrects them by saying that Goku has
been using the kaio-ken technique all
along as kids watching this for the
first time that revelation completely
floored us we never saw it coming the
move that we treated as Goku's
ace-in-the-hole for many battles
suddenly was worthless against Frieza
myself and my brother looked at each
other both of us now understood how
insignificant Goku was in comparison to
freezer while only using half of his
full power Goku who had been confident
up until that point to rely
is the gravity of the situation humbled
by Frieza
but not only that even we the viewers
underestimated freezes enormous power
he not only embarrassed the Z warriors
on Namek and at King Kai's place but
also Goku and many of the viewers
watching at home around the world - it
was a moment I will never forget that
feeling of and it is unquestionably in
my view the top moment Frieza
embarrassed his opponent so guys did I
miss out on your favorite moment or do
you think I got the order on if you guys
would like to see more continent top
tens like this one don't forget to leave
a like and submit and maybe you know
think about hitting that subscribe
button so you can be the first person to
know well I make a new video with that
said this has been the top 10 times
Frieza embarrassed his opponents I've
been told not mark and as always thank
you so much for watching